certains le disent en difficulté qu'ils
auraient misé sur une vire à clarac
finalement bas il se rend compte que
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que prévu
notamment du fait de la résistance des
ukrainiens des civils aussi il ne peut
pas perdre la face vladimir poutine ce
qui inquiète d'autres commentateurs de
cette crise et c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup entendu parler ces derniers
jours on a vu qu'il avait fait appel aux
tchétchènes qu'il avait fait appel aux
milices syrienne certains redoute qu'ils
n'utilisent larmes chimiques contre les
ukrainiens ça fait partie des options
possibles alors ça fait partie des
options possibles dans la mesure où il
l'a déjà utilisé ce type d'armes mais
pour des assassinats ciblés
assassinats ciblés de d'opposants pas
forcément en russie mais d'opposants qui
était justement opposant à poutine dans
les marges de la russie donc ça il sait
faire
les miliciens syriens et les tchétchènes
de kadirov ça aussi c'est important
parce que ça veut dire que c'est une
manière d'élever le seuil de violence
on ne sait pas exactement comment par
exemple les fantassins russe cantine son
monde et conscrits quand ils sont d
appeler peuvent se comporter dans ce cas
de figure est ce qu'ils sont capables de
se battre manifestement il ya un doute
là dessus
d'où l'envoi de ces miliciens qui eux
sont des véritables tueurs ils sont
payés pour ça ou et oui souvent payé
d'ailleurs et donc ils élèvent le seuil
de violence est ce que tout ce qui
concerne le chimique est aussi une
manière évidemment défrayés mais vous
savez aussi que dans la rhétorique du
kremlin il est assez fréquent que l'on
parle de quelque chose en n'accusant le
camp adverse de sorte que on se prépare
soi même à utiliser ses seins pour
pouvoir accuser les autres de les avoir
employé donc ça aussi c'est qu'un
envisage déjà que la russie accusé
l'ukraine d'avoir utilisé les armes
chimiques pour pouvoir les utiliser par
la suite par la suite alors il y a
effectivement il ya un bâtiment qui
centralise des recherches en ukraine est
une collaboration entre l'ouest et
l'ukraine sur des questions
chimiques on ne sait pas quelles sont
les agents pathogènes mais l' oms a dit
à l'ukraine écouter désarmé cette usine
c'est pas la peine de fournir un
prétexte à vladimir poutine mais en tout
cas oui tout tout est pensable en ce
sens que comme le nucléaire d'ailleurs
le nucléaire tactique pourrait être
employé par poutine à condition qu'ils
aient le sentiment que ça soit utile et
c'est ça encore une fois le problème je
terminerais là dessus que ce soit utile
à quoi a gagné la guerre oui sans doute
mais surtout a gagné la stature de
grandeur qui l'espère pour lui et qu'il
espère pour son pays même si pour cela
il doit mener son propre pays à la bim
vous voyez pour la diplomatie c'est
extrêmement compliqué de prendre en
compte en prendre en considération ces
éléments là et c'est vrai que ça il
s'agit pas du tout de faire de la
psychologie de vladimir poutine je veux
dire par là que tout un pan de la
société réussit prêts à le suivre et
dans l'administration russe aussi on
voit pas pour l'instant des bruissements
qui pourrait indiquer à une révolution
de palais où un renversement de la
lumière poutine